so so l.a
you're probably going to be there for a
few years you don't see yourself leaving
anytime soon uh you know look i live i
live close to the beach i live in a
really cool part of la where are you at
manhattan beach okay yeah that's that's
right that's where our friend's center's
at center's there yeah yeah that's not
really california though correct by the
way we just came back from la we were
there i mean at least when we went
together
the first time we were there in 2020
coveted lockdown it was a [ __ ] show and
we just went back and we were like and
mario was like let's go to venice and
see what's going on
how shocked with you how nice it was oh
it's great i i i we were personally in
homeless people no they cleaned they
cleaned it up
when was this one of those because
during two days ago during covert was
the worst but now yeah i own a house in
venice yeah and uh it's i'm holding on
to it because it's what chur what turned
around in l.a because it's better than
it was because the sheriff's department
okay went down and they were doing a
live news conference and the woman
almost got knifed by somebody you would
see naked people these people are
the the homeless situation the narrative
from the the left is that it's a housing
problem and it's an inequality problem
they are liars they're liars um it's
it's an ideology they hold on to and
they're not interested in solving the
problem sorry go to go to sacramento and
tell them uh that it's a
um
it's a mental health and drug addiction
problem is that what it is and it is and
when coveted hit those services kind of
evaporated for a lot of people
and that's why you had so many people on
the street um so the idea that it's a
housing problem and its inequality is is
not only a lie it's a malicious lie
because it doesn't do anything for those
people who really do need help they need
help a lot of these people are
schizophrenic they have serious mental
health problems that are beyond their
control
and i think it was adam carolla who said
if if there were a bunch of stray dogs
on the street in los angeles believe me
we'd do something 1000 but these are
people so whatever uh you know and and
i'm sorry but if you look at the blue
estates they have the worst homeless
they have the worst they have the most
progressive tax policies they have the
worst homeless uh inequality problems
because they're not really willing to
take it on to go to san francisco and
tell me how that's working out because
with their d.a and and all those all
those essentially those marxists in in
power can they turn it around because
it's
california
who's running for mayor of l.a caruso
are you following that story or not yes
and i and it seems pretty cool well he's
he's he's made he's made the world worse
so could this tough on crime billionaire
be allah's next mayor
i think so it's tapping into fears of
crime los angeles frustration can you
make that a little bit bigger
homelessness billionaire real estate
developer has uh spent more than 23
million on his campaign to become la's
next tough on crime mayor and experts
say his record-breaking investment is
buying him a real chance at victory wow
interesting he's because people after a
while every society after a while looks
around and says this isn't working man
this is not working it it it's it just
doesn't yeah we're the cause and
especially when you're paying that much
tax and what are you spending it on yeah
yeah i mean like you can help these
people and a lot of more vets yeah a lot
of those guys what do you think it's
gonna take for for you for california to
have a republican governor
well we had a republican governor the
the the issue isn't
republican governor i think the most of
the politics is all
local right so the larger question isn't
focusing on the gubernatorial race and
things like that
it's more about local politics we have a
democratic super majority i don't think
a democratic super majority i don't
think a super majority of republicans or
anything is good you need
you need pushback you you want there to
be this this argument these checks these
balances you want push pushback on both
sides that's how government churns
slowly and stays out of our business
there's an important distinction when
you talk about big government versus
small government
big government is
not you you have to be careful of how
you define these things big government
go ahead it's really a question of when
that government gets
involved in your individual liberties in
your ability to make money use your own
risk your own ingenuity to make you know
a profit those kinds of things when when
when a government bureaucrat comes along
and regardless of the science says you
still have to be in a mask and my
children still have to be in a mask i
have a problem with that you're actually
interfering in my child's well-being
because you have an ideology you know
whatever that might be i'm using that as
a hard example i know that's a
controversial issue but i think we have
to be very careful about how we draw
that distinction
in la what they need to worry about is i
think it's five women on the la city
council
who control a budget that's larger than
i think
all 40 other states right or in fact it
might be 40 states combined they have
they control a huge budget and it's five
of these women that i'm sorry are you
know i don't want the view
i want to i want a mix bro i want a mix
of people it's not about i'm not bashing
women it's about you know i just want a
mix of people i'd like hey you know what
i want controlling the budget people
that have have made a business work so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]